foreign
hey sarge
okay mcgillicuddy
when you gotta go you gotta hey look out
mac
though shalt not use any spots except
chosen ones for the
deposition of your excrement
thou shalt not urinate in thy brother's
tent
or street elsie regard thee as a dog
and tree accordingly
in other words that means use your head
avoid contaminating any area which could
result in dysentery for your entire unit
i gotta go to the toilet
so
hey stupid can't you read
well look at that mcgillicuddy's private
one holder
what a layout sanjay
library toilet tissue
beautiful view even gardenias
and a hell of a good home for dysentery
what a germs yeah what a
come and dope at it
oh look at that
uh
um
and now because of one man's
carelessness a whole unit is flat on its
back
news we discover we have in the south
pacific
yankee marine who helped our japanese
war effort
this a yankee all the time make
honorable bowel movement in
wrong location or his buddy yankee get a
dysertary
oh make a week like a pussycat this
honorable yankee named magirati
go get em boys
nope
mcgillicuddy you made your bed now live